And then eights in a week because I would thought, Oh, it's wrong. It's wrong.
It's gotta be wrong. If you think it is wrong.
But if you take it on playful and that's what I do right now,
there's no thought I make it to ridiculous this hostile force.
There's so negative. Overwhelming called prime,
orderly primordial early at Gatton to us that it is
dangerous and all, I make it a laugh and joke and that, eh,
you see everybody having fun. That's only in denied.
One day came to me after fatiguing travel from wherever they come
from Hawaii to Australia, to New Zealand, to Japan, to Russia,
they all come there and fatiguing traveling.
They feel renewed and they sleep like babies.
That is the night number one. And then the,
in the morning they are excited, but they also like,
Oh, what happened? I don't know.
Maybe I cannot believe what happened then that I
into the breathing.
And then you had the biggest yelling of a releasing drama.
And I go to the ancestors and everything because I know how
to open up the closed up proteins because of drugs.
What do you mean that you go to the ancestors? What do you mean by that?
That is anything that is genetically encrypted in our gene
expressions and closed up is because of a genetical past.
Hey, so why do you write you?
Why do you specifically refer to that as the ancestors?
What made you think that?
Because we are the ancestors within our DNA,
we carry every inflammation of our ancestry,
like 13, like possibly a hundred,
as long as it is not solved. It's still within us.
I've just, I've just written a new book and there's this I,
it's not out till March. There's a section in there.
There's an old mythological idea that the hero has to
rescue his, his sleeping father from the abyss,
from a terrible monster.
And I construed that in the book as the ability
to awaken sleeping,
ancestral forces likely coded genetically as a consequence of
voluntary exposure to stress.
Yes. That we come together. Jonah.
This is what I do right now in San Francisco showing
through, uh, uh,
bringing back to you the primal primordial condition of the cell
to get it with the culture shock each up proteins.
What happens when you do practically? Yes, yes,
you do this. If you go record laterally in the cold,
then the activation of those cold shock proteins to the old Joey
chalk, because it's the same thing. It's through the hypothalamus and it works.
Boom, we get connection.
And then suddenly you bring a protective shield around the cell.
What happens inside the war is over guys. We can go into repair.
And then you noodle signaling. We talked about notice sickly.
I was able to bring a cold water under skin, skin temperature, not go down.
That is how can you do that for how long can I maintain it? As long as it takes,
as long as it takes, that is the power of our mind intention.
It's a real undiscovered area of psychiatry,
which I have discovered together with a professor by Bob,
Divakar a professor auto music and a Detroit.
Do you have the universe have to eat more because of that? No, no, no,
absolutely not. It's the power of your intention.
Your intention is able,
this is a general universal principle of our
mind. Only not awakened to,
what's not discovered the first time somebody ran the four miles in
a certain incredible year. Later 20 could do it.
That's the mind.
So what we find is if we expose it to
people, then they begin, they change their paradigm, the paradigm,
this is what they say. We,
when mouth has found the secret of placebo,
placebo is no longer just over their head.
It's now with controllable healing force, whenever you need it.
It's the top down regulated,
entailed reception it's in, within our will. That's the new science.
And that, that brings us back to the ancestry.
So first we make this cell protected by a
shield, activating the culture.
Each are proteins that inside the cell,
you get a logically is sick note. Hey, there is no war anymore.
Energy is not needed to get inflammation out of it or to deal with inflammation
or oxidative stress. Oh, let's go into the, uh, uh,
the close-up proteins of our ancestry.
We can work it up now because now it's silent now. It's nice.
Now we got the energy pieces here.
This is the principle at general principle of nature. When you a wound, it,
you re retract, but if you are a war, you do,
you can even a coupon and shoot it with a Lakoff
shot. That's adrenaline cortisol.
That mode just keeps on going. That's what society that is all till wrong.
There is no, there is no, uh, ability to retract.
No more work needs to be done daily. Uh, uh, uh,
how do you say, uh, uh, these, uh, yeah, what have,
I would need to be done all the time. It projects.
Your people in Poland the first day. You,
you have them go outside in the cold for a long period of time with,
with no shoes on, for example,
and they wake up the next day and you introduce them to the breathing. If,
if someone's doing this at home, like if, if I wanted to start this tomorrow,
I get up and have a cold shower and I would,
I would do that voluntarily as facing the stress. Okay.
And then how would I, how would I do the breathing?
Would I do that after the shower? Would I do that in the afternoon?
When would I do that?
You do it whenever you are completely rested,
like relaxed,
because the breathing will open up your physiology deeply.
If you go into deep stress while being a
kind of, okay, that is the breathing,
the breathing exercises is a workout because the vascular
system is more activated than somebody who's running.
You see, uh, lately I did a,
a research with paralyzed people. Amazing.
I can't, I can't do it when I'm relaxed because I'm never relaxed.
But you can, you can,
you will directly intervene into,
into the neurological anxiety going on,
whatever is on the loose.
You will be able to create a extra altered current,
uh, within, uh, electrical current, the nervous system does it will be able to.
Does it not matter when I do it then, like I could.
Do a dust dock, Metta.
I mean, I wasn't able to do it with you.
Empty stomach. If you need me, I'm there any time you can call me,
we have a zoom and we do it, but you don't need me.
I like to talk with you. Cause you got, you got a great, uh,
experience in words and a contemplation and a lot of expertise.
And I think we coincide a lot, like just now about the stress,
the ancestry.
That took me like 15 years to figure out, because I've read all these stories.
They're ancient stories.
That first the core element of the hero's journey,
which is the proper journey through life is voluntary confrontation with what is
unknown and terrifying. That's the human way.
And one of the consequence of that is the rescuing of the dead father or the
hurt father or the sleeping father. It like,
it's a fundamental of Egyptian mythology, for example,
ancient Egyptian mythology. And it's,
it's part of the idea of the dying and resurrecting God it's, it's,
it's entangled up in that as well.
And it wasn't until recently that I figured out that the consequence of
voluntarily facing stress is the awakening of abilities within
you that are part of our ancestral heritage.
And so that is how you become a living avatar of the great heroes of the
past, but I never, it never occurred to me that, that,
that you could find high stress SIRS of a, of a safe,
physical type. So close at hand. I never,
I never really put that together. The idea that cold stress, for example,
would be sufficient to start that process. What about heat?
Stress? I found saunas were actually useful for me, fasting, fasting,
fasting.
All those were great. Fast thing is for me, he says huge stress on me.
He says, uh, the cold stress,
but the breathing really it,
these breathing techniques, let me compare it.
It's been compared in brain scan studies of people doing
four hours of mindfulness a day for years,
they could not get as,
as deep as a person practicing this type of, uh,
breathing exercises, go into the depth of the brain.
They could not get into the depth of the brain, even after years,
four hours of mindfulness a day. And these, uh, what we did,
we went deeper inside the brain, then dose people. So this,
and that's in 30 breaths. Yes, this exercise, uh, which,
uh, began with going into the cold. It made me
that's the first thing. Then you learn that through prolonged,
deep breathing,
you learn to control the biochemistry insight to, uh,
to shake off the, uh, stressor,
which is the cold and dust prolonged time in cold water.
You find that out and it's all based on experience and sensation and it works.
Okay.
Then I began to disconnect the breathing from the goal called I
still was doing a teacher, but then I did these breathing exercises,
uh, at, Oh, and they blew my mind.
Anything that I had read in all the Asian scriptures,
I saw plenty. Oh, Oh, Oh, and deeper.
And now I found that these breathing exercises are able to go
with our paradigm with medical science thought of is
impossible.
And I'm showing this now I know you are
practicing.
Conscious control over a semi unconscious function when you're exerting
control over your breathing and breathing is strange because it does occur
unconsciously, but we can also modify it consciously.
So it's right at the it's right at the, what would you say?
The border between consciousness and unconsciousness?
Interesting. Yeah, it's a good point. A good point. Uh,
it's a good point of view. It is.
And we modulator,
we modulate our breathing voluntarily all the time when we're speaking.
And someone's also associated with the.
[Inaudible] amazing. Yes. Uh, that, that is so and done.
We saw in the brain scans in Germany and Hanover,
one of the best two brain scans of the world doing this breathing.
Normally we have a willful control over 60% of our
neural activity in our brain.
And now they saw a hundred percent noodle activation
within the brain, Don consciously,
because we were doing the breathing exercises.